what happens when a liberal journalist
attends a trump rally amongst the actual
people writing in the Chicago Sun Times
columnist Neil Steinberg recounts last
week's President presidential rally that
happened with the steelworkers never
counted it this way we need steal Trump
said we need steel plants I look at the
faces of you people I could be one of
you I like you guys well that struck me
as either sincere or an amazing
facsimile the workers for their part
couldn't give him a standing ovation
because they never sat down I left the
hall thinking Donald Trump is going to
be reelected in 2020 the Democrats don't
have anyone who can touch him Bank on it
don't hate me for being the one to tell
you hmm
joining me now for reaction is Ben
Shapiro editor of The Daily wire Ben I
read that and I thought that's at least
an honest liberal view he hates Trump
you can't stand Trump but going to a
rally and seeing the reaction of the
people and thinking Kamala Harris or
Cory Booker are they really gonna get
the get the Mojo going what are your
thoughts there I think it's exactly
right I mean the culture war that's been
raging in the country is really not a
war between the elites and the non
elites is between the elitists and
everyone else people who think that jobs
being lost at the New York Daily News is
a national tragedy but jobs being lost
in the steel industry is totally fine
because those are a bunch of rubes in
the Rust Belt so anyway what President
Trump really does better than virtually
any other politician on the American
scene is he he conveys that he really
does care about people who are in these
industries the people who are doing the
the so-called dirty jobs that people on
the coasts tend to think only illegal
immigrants are willing to do yeah Ben I
was I did my angle that tonight on the
Koch brothers who've done a lot of good
stuff on tax reform and supporting Brett
Kavanaugh and tax you know deregulation
excuse me they've done good stuff on
that but they are just adamant that even
discussing tariffs it's gonna crater the
global economy it's gonna be trouble
they have 60,000 or 65,000 workers
overseas they have 60,000 in the United
States but they have a lot overseas so
they're the old Republican Guard and
they want they don't like this and
they're gonna start funding some
Democrats because they
to fight that Trump approach to trade
well I think obviously funding Democrats
is not the answer to this I'm a free
trader myself and I'm not particularly
fond of tariff policy but the real key
here again I think it's less policy
driven than it is even cultural the
president obviously has a lot of
sympathy for people who are in these
industries that that have paid a price
due to trade I mean there's no question
that there are winners and losers in
trade overall I think the trade is a
great thing for the United States I
think free trade is a great thing for
the United States but to pretend that
there are no downsides to trade is
obviously not telling the whole truth
yeah well I think that again the results
of the election and those Rust Belt
states and they suffered the great job
losses over the last 20 years of China
being in the WTO I mean it's all these
all these neocon Hawks been who all they
did is tell us you know we got to build
up to military got to build up the
military that's great
I agree but China is the big threat to
America's dominance militarily and
economically and so if we just grow
their economy at the expense of our own
we're gonna be in some trouble down the
road I also want you to get to get some
thoughts from you on something that's
kind of the opposite of what that
Chicago Sun Times columnist wrote this
was a piece published this morning
imagining the day after Trump's
re-election loss in 2020 okay here it is
as Trump sieved and tweeted in defeat
late Tuesday and president-elect
Elizabeth Warren celebrated the arc of
the Trump story is starting to make more
sense than it has for much of his
chaotic presidency the normal rules of
politics do apply to Donald Trump after
all so now the time the time was up for
Trump they're already imagining his loss
which tells you well the derangement
Center whatever you want to call it that
cliche is already wearing nothing but
they're now having to write about 2020
in 2018 yeah well then I think they're
desperate to to take down president from
right now they are hoping obviously the
2016 was an outlier and they're gonna
blame it on anything they'll blame it on
Hillary Clinton being a bad candidate
finally or they'll blame it on Russian
collusion which they've yet to prove but
they what they won't acknowledge that
there's a systemic problem inside the
Democratic Party and screaming Medicare
for all and running a Hillary Clinton
clone like Elizabeth Warren is not going
to fix the giant gap that they have with
the middle of the country who may still
consider a bunch of bitter clingers
working jobs they would never deign to
get their hands dirty doing listen I'm a
guy
who's from the coast right I'm from LA I
spent some of my time in Cambridge
Massachusetts I am an elite by any of
these standards but the bottom line is
that the people in the middle of the
country are doing work that is as
important or more important than the
people on the coast who are sitting in
their coffee houses writing scripts well
but you don't you know you're not
necessarily an elite just because you go
to those nice institutions if you
understand the plight of the regular
working person and you think that they
have a role in our economy you're not on
oh wait you're someone who went to this
I'm not elitist and I didn't Trump
actually made this distinction FLE
recently he said listen the problem is
audiences in this audience are you're
good at your job if you work hard if you
do well meditates you are an elite by
any standard but you're not an elitist
and that's where the Democrats get it
wrong all right yeah I think being an
elitist is the important thought Ben
Shapiro awesome segment as always thanks